one thing is quite clear the current
crisis is not going to pass in a few
months i spoke very early on about a
turning point and this is what we are
talking about here
russia's war of aggression against
ukraine has changed everything and at
the same time supply chains have still
not recovered from the pandemic and
general uncertainty is growing
fixed
well that was german chancellor olav
schultz at a meeting with trade unions
on monday driving home his message that
europe's largest economy will take a hit
as the war in ukraine shows no sign of
ending soon germany like most countries
reporting inflation rates not seen in
decades the cost of living of
skyrocketing and now germany's export
machine its ability to sell to the world
is looking weaker numbers out for the
month of may show that for the first
time in 30 years germany recorded a
trading deficit imports into germany
were worth nearly a billion euros more
than german exports in that month
unusual times my colleague janelle
demalian from bw business joins me now
you know janelle we hear about the u.s
having a trade deficit with china we've
been hearing about that now for years
but not germany right so it makes it a
big deal doesn't it indeed we've arrived
at different territory for germany after
it spent years enjoying this trade
surplus and you know just going back a
little i suppose what makes it different
from different from the us is that
germany had a strategy to get that trade
surplus and it was of cost management it
was able to keep its costs low so just
as an example it
it employed wage restraints so
agreements between unions and employers
to keep wage hikes in check and that
kept costs low for the companies and
german products more competitive on the
international market but perhaps more
relevant to our discussion today
germany also bought cheap russian energy
and that powered the manufacturing
machine that delivered those made in
germany products to
the us to china to russia
and you know if your strategy is being
able to produce cheaply well that's not
proving to be so tenable anymore as you
know as you say the cost of living rises
everything is more expensive across the
board and that's why we're seeing
the you know this trade deficit for the
first time in a very long time in
europe's biggest economy and we've got
so we've we've got you know these issues
you brought up particularly the cost of
energy and
this is not going to go away anytime
soon so what is this going to mean then
for
germany's future as
yeah europe's export champion
well you know this trade deficit is a
monthly figure right but it's so hard to
try and figure out what's going to
happen to germany in the long run when
so many short-term things are unclear so
just to give you an example in the next
days
russia is expected to cut off gas flows
to germany via the nordstream one
pipeline for
you know for 10 days as it undergoes
some scheduled maintenance and it's just
not clear whether russia is going to
turn on those taps again after that
maintenance is over and you know this
prospect of
more things contributing to the energy
supply crunch is another uh cause for a
headache for germany's economic policy
makers but essentially what we're seeing
is energy insecurity really threatening
this uh
model that underpinned german prosperity
for such a long time and it's hard to
see germany going back to business as
usual or just the way it was after that
there have been plenty of critics of
the trade surplus that germany has had
now for years so those critics what do
they make of what's happening now
well it's true that the trade surplus
had many critics you know the fact that
germany was able to
make its products more competitive by
design meant that germany had an edge
and that pushed out other countries
products and there were really things
that germany could have done more such
as raising wages and increasing public
expenditure but
brent i don't really think that this was
the rebalancing that other countries
were looking for these things like
snarled up supply chain energy costs and
inflation now it's not just going to be
germany that is changed by all of this
so
that's exactly right
the supply chain issues alone impacting
everyone and anyone who gets anything
delivered and that's actually almost
everyone on the planet
janelle demalion from dw business as
always janelle thank you thank you
you